the land was ours before we were the
lands those are the words of Robert
Frost but they could have been uttered
by the pilgrims
who were convinced of a divine
providence guiding their voyage on the
Mayflower to found a new canaan in the
new world
I'm convinced of it too we will explain
the true story of the Mayflower the
pilgrims Thanksgiving and our national
destiny and any talk of the American
destiny needs to include little Commerce
little capitalism a little productivity
and that's why we need to thank our
sponsor movement watches holiday
shopping can be tough but thanks to
movement all that gift-giving anxiety
can disappear with the press of a button
movement watches I'm wearing one right
now they make the perfect purchase for
just about anyone in your life guy or
girl man or woman you know we're all
free and loving today they started only
$95
I love watch serious people wear watches
and movement offers an incredibly sleek
stylish watch that will not bankrupt you
at a department store these things could
be like four or five hundred dollars but
movement skips all of that they go right
online you can get them at a really
affordable price starts at only $95 they
have totally disrupted the watch
industry they offer high quality
minimalist products at revolutionary
prices that's probably why they've sold
over 1 million watches in over 160
countries around the world and today
what a reason to be thankful my
listeners will get 15% off with free
shipping and returns by going to MDM
t.com slash cough fa that's CoV fe fe
movement comm MVM T comm slash cough
epic this watch has a really clean
design it makes a great fashion
statement now is the time to step up
your watch game if not now when if not
us who MVM t.com slash cough fa CoV Fe
Fe join the movement all right back to
Thanksgiving the founding of our country
now that we got a little capitalism
going on the left today mocks claims of
a divine hand in our founding and the
founding of our country I think the
reason they can so easily dismiss
Providence is because they're almost
entirely ignorant of the history this is
why they'll also claim that purely
benevolent Indians selflessly saved the
pilgrims from
our vation only to be betrayed by the
English ingrates and callously wiped out
that didn't really happen Thanksgiving
is the cause of much historical myth
making I don't mean the divine
providence of the pilgrims passage that
part is undeniable I don't mean the
myths of the patriotic variety that the
Pilgrims and the natives sat down they
shared food and goods together they
forged bonds of friendship and peace all
of that happened to I mean the myths of
revisionism war came no doubt but the
circumstances under which war came after
55 years of relatively unbroken peace is
far more complicated than the
revisionists would claim the pilgrims
were not greedy conquistadores and the
Indians weren't helpless innocence war
might have come sooner peace might have
persisted for longer but for the actions
and decisions of particular men reacting
to complex circumstances I personally
have a particular interest in the
Mayflower voyagers because despite my
swarthy Sicilian skin tone I descend
from four of them only one of them was a
pilgrim dr. Samuel fuller he was the
only physician in the colony although
his medical training is somewhat
doubtful my credentials are a little
doubtful two three of them were
so-called strangers these were the non
pilgrim passengers on the Mayflower they
were not religious zealots some of them
were downright degenerate one Gregory
Gregory Gregory great-grandpappy Knowles
is Stephen Hopkins who 11 years prior to
the Mayflower's voyage had already
traveled to the new world and he had
shipwrecked in Bermuda an incident on
which Shakespeare's The Tempest is based
another is Francis Eaton and the third
is John Billington who Plymouth Governor
William Bradford called a knave with a
family that was quote one of the Pro
famous tamang them Gregory
great-grandpappy Billington appears to
have been the biggest degenerate of the
Plymouth gang he was regularly punished
for rabble rousing and eventually he was
executed for murder
his son John wandered off and almost
caused a war and his wife Eleanor was
sentenced to sit in the stocks and be
whipped for slander family memories they
come back to me enough about my derelict
ancestors back to the Providence did God
ordained the Mayflower passage and the
founding of America governor Bradford
certainly thought so in his account of
Plymouth Plantation
he wrote of the group they knew they
were pilgrims that's why we call the
Voyageurs pilgrims they wrote of
themselves quote we verily believe and
trust the Lord is with us and that he
will graciously prosper our endeavors
according to the simplicity of our
hearts therein it is not with us as with
other men whom small things can
discourage or small discontentment
caused to wish themselves home again
that was a good thing because just about
every obstacle imaginable appeared to
prevent the Mayflower's voyage the
pilgrims for those who don't know they
came from a separatist church that
thought the Church of England was so
corrupt it could not possibly be
reformed from within and must be opposed
from without one can only imagine what
they would think of my own potpourri one
of their descendants in the sixteenth
century several separatists had been
jailed and killed and since the 16:03
coronation of King James pressure to
conform began to mount so the pilgrims
left England for Leiden Holland after a
decade there the group feared their
children were becoming too Dutch a fate
worse than death and so they decided to
found a new colony in the new world
where they could worship God as they saw
fit unmolested by overbearing
governments and those decadent Dutch
those damned decadent Dutch but as they
prepared to depart pilgrim William
Brewster published a tract critical of
King James and his bishops now as a
young man Brewster had served as an
assistant to Queen Elizabeth's Secretary
of State a man named William Davison and
now the king ordered his arrest which
forced Brewster into hiding not a good
time nevertheless they persisted the
pilgrims contracted master Christopher
Jones and his sweet ship the Mayflower
along with another vessel called the
Speedwell the Mayflower was called a
sweet ship because it had sailed the
English Channel for over a decade
carrying French wine and the spilt
French wine tempered the stench of the
bilge on the ship some might see the
pervading presence of the wine in this
first act of departure the first miracle
performed by Christ and a symbol of
Christ himself as an early glimpse of
God's plan for the pilgrims regardless
more trouble lay ahead the second ship
the Speedwell sprang a leak after
reaching Southampton and another at
Dartmouth having decided that the ship
was
unable to sail all of the passengers
loaded up on the Mayflower only later
was it learned that the speed Wells
master captain Reynolds had been
conspiring against the pilgrims it was
no mistake
the Dutch you remember those damn
decadent Dutch they had sought to
prevent the English from settling
Manhattan and so they enlisted Reynolds
in their efforts to thwart the
transatlantic voyage ironically this act
of sabotage may have saved the colony in
its early years by forcing all of the
passengers onto one ship the separatists
and the strangers had to learn to
cooperate with one another had the
Speedwell survived there likely would
have been very little contact between
the two groups one was drawn to one ship
one to the other
now the pilgrims saw evidence of God's
work in just about everything it's an
evil generation that looks for signs and
wonders but it's a stupid generation
that ignores signs and wonders almost
immediately a sailor began to mock the
pilgrims seasickness you can imagine at
sea hardened sailor starts making fun of
these Christian zealots as Bradford
tells it quote a proud and profane young
man would always be condemning our poor
people in their sickness and cursing
them daily with grievous execrations the
young man boasted of hoping quote to
help to cast half of them overboard
before they came to their journey's end
Radford goes on though but it pleased
God before they came half seas over to
smite this young man with a grievous
disease of which he died in a desperate
manner and so was himself the first that
was thrown overboard not to put too fine
a point on the incident and what it
meant for the pilgrims project bradford
wrote quote it was an astonishment to
all his fellows for they noted it to be
the just hand of God upon him the rest
of the sailors kept their mouths shut
smartguides after 65 days the Mayflower
made landfall not at their intended and
legally granted destination of New York
but hundreds of miles northeast at Cape
Cod where the settlers had no legal
right to the land
they'd been granted land by the Hudson
River but not where they landed when the
passengers learned of this a group of
mutineers led by not one but two of my
ancestors rose up to make quote
discontented and mutinous speeches
fortunately a few on board listened to
them and the voyagers signed the
Mayflower Compact a quote covenant to
combine ourselves together in a civil
body politic for our better order
and preservation and furtherance of the
ends of horse said the land was not much
to look at
Bradford called it quote a hideous and
desolate wilderness stranger than the
environment however was its lack of
people there just wasn't anybody around
it was unpeopled because between 1616
and 1619 bubonic plague or some similar
disease was introduced by European
fishermen in modern Maine it killed an
estimated 90% of the inhabitants of New
England the disease prompted an outbreak
of war among various tribes vying for
power in the chaos people died so
quickly no one remained to bury the dead
which left the pilgrims to wonder at the
whitened bones lying in cleared fields
the Indians already had some familiarity
with Europeans in 1614 Captain John
Smith of Pocahontas Fame that won the
cartoon guy he led a voyage around the
region during which his commander Thomas
hunt captured and enslaved a group of
natives this led the Indians to
slaughter all but three or four of a
later group of French travelers who
shipwrecked on Cape Cod the next year in
1615 the men who were spared ended up
being tortured and enslaved but one of
them promised an Indian in the Indians
own language that God was angry with
them for their wickedness and would
destroy them and give their country to
another people this was a prophecy
doubtless fulfilled and another evidence
of the almighty plan for the pilgrims by
Provincetown Harbor where the pilgrims
first landed they found a gigantic
bushel of corn they just found it
sitting there is hewed they were
starving they were worried about their
ability to feed themselves and there was
just a huge sack of corn so much that
two men could not carry all of it and
they debated whether or not to take it
but they feared starvation so they
decided to grab the corn and compensate
the bushels owner later on because as
you know it's easier to ask forgiveness
than permission the pilgrims did however
refused to loot what appeared to be
Indian burial places despite finding
bows and arrows there certainly they
would have been useful to the pilgrims
but they said quote it would be odious
unto them to ransack their sepulchers
within a short spell at least thirty
Indians descended on the pilgrims
screaming war cries and flinging arrows
miraculously not a single Mayflower
passenger left the encounter with a
scratch they realize their new neighbors
were not
well disposed toward them so Bradford
set out to look for a better settlement
option after a month he discovered
Plymouth Bay where the situation was
even stranger there were whole fields
perfectly cleared for agriculture but
there were no people to cultivate them
Bradford saw in this a clear sign from
the Lord of a place that they randomly
found apparently randomly found
perfectly cleared and ready for them to
plant he returned to the Mayflower to
share his discovery he was so thankful
to God but upon returning tragedy struck
Bradford learned that Dorothea may his
wife of seven years and mother of his
three year old son had slipped over the
side of the Mayflower and drowned
you might be thinking hmm it's difficult
to slip over the side of an anchored
boat and you would be right well
historian Cotton Mather called the death
an accident many believed it to have
been a suicide the temptation to despair
was strong Dorothy may hadn't seen her
son in four months a seven-year-old
child on the ship had just died and two
more children were ill to the point of
death on top of all of that and on top
of the typically cold New England
weather a little ice age had descended
on the region until Bradford's return
five days after his wife's death
the Mayflower passengers had little
reason to expect their lot would improve
Bradford himself then fell ill as the
voyagers settled into Plymouth he
requested some beer from the Mayflower
to aid in his recovery the sailor is
fearful that their booze supply would
run out before they made it back to
England well the water at that time was
virtually undrinkable so they needed to
drink beer on the way they responded
that if Bradford were their own father
he should have none quote remember what
happened to the last sailor who gave
pilgrims lip you might remember in a
replay of that incident they all started
to get sick and died the coincidence
even prompted one young officer on the
ship to a deathbed conversion Master
Jones too had a change of heart and he
gave the pilgrims their beer smart guy
during February and March of that
horrible winter two or three colonists
died per day two or three per day by
spring a majority of the settlers who
had originally arrived at Provincetown
fifty two out of a hundred and two were
dead here's where things start to get
really really strange as if they weren't
strange enough already
here's where it gets to Occam's razor on
March 16th just two or three months
after settling in at Plymouth
a lone Indian walked boldly out of the
woods toward the pilgrims they grabbed
their muskets stood on guard
none of that deterred the Indian he
saluted his new neighbors and said two
words welcomed Englishman he was tall he
had long hair no beard he was naked as
the day he was born
interestingly for the racial politics
revisionists the pilgrims made no
mention in their records of his race of
the color of his skin the man's name was
Samoset he was a sachem visiting from
Maine where he learned some English from
fishermen and he just happened to be
visiting in precisely the area at
precisely the time the English had
accidentally landed after they'd missed
New York but didn't know to sail up to
the next nicest Harbor in Massachusetts
Bay just right there right exactly where
they were apparently by accident if that
weren't coincidental enough in the
following days Samoset returned with
another Indian who spoke virtually
perfect English he chatted with the
pilgrims about his favorite areas of
Spain and his favorite neighborhoods in
London that man's name was Squanto years
earlier Squanto had been abducted by
Thomas hunt sold into slavery in Spain
escaped or was possibly rescued by monks
made his way to England somehow hopped a
boat to Newfoundland and walked all the
way down to Plymouth where the pocono
could Indian Chief Massasoit enslaved
him the Pokanoket Indian chief right
near where the Pilgrims landed right at
the mark that they happened to land the
pilgrims after landing 300 miles off
their mark stumbled on perhaps the only
person in the Western Hemisphere with a
command of the English language this is
the Occam's razor part Occam's razor
says among competing hypotheses the one
with the fewest assumptions should be
selected so either endless unique and
impossibly improbable events just happen
to occur or God sent Squanto to help the
pilgrims I know which one I think
Squanto unsurprisingly became the
liaison between the pilgrims and their
new neighbors the Pokanoket William
Brewster ever the diplomat orchestrated
a diplomatic reception of the Pokanoket
sachem Massa so it replete with pillows
and carpets and trumpets and drums
within only a few years Squanto had gone
from a slave to the single most powerful
person in the region as only he could
communicate between the English and the
Indians and he used his newfound power
to his advantage Squanto
a true friend of the Indians he helped
them plant corn he was indispensable
governor Bradford loved him like a
family member he also played the
situation to get an upper hand on NASA
so it and the Pocono cats there's a bit
of strange symbolism in the name squanto
itself
Squanto was named after the Indians
spirit of night and darkness and cold
wind spirit the pilgrims identified with
the devil there was another one another
indispensable Indian to the pilgrims a
man by the name of hob amok was also
named after this spirit Nathaniel
Philbrick in his excellent story the
Mayflower and his excellent book he puts
it well a group of people so singularly
devoted to serving God that they sailed
halfway around the world to do it became
entirely dependent on two Indians named
Satan the surrounding Indian tribes in
turn became jealous of the Pokanoket
Indian Alliance as it greatly
strengthened masses so its position in
the region the Mattapoisett chief
Corbett on tried to break the alliance
by capturing poor little Squanto he even
held a knife to the poor man's neck
but while the pilgrims were generally
peaceful it is nevertheless and always
remains a bad idea
to mess with fire and brimstone zealots
who know they have God on their side
governor Bradford ordered Plymouth's
military commander Myles Standish to go
after Corbett on with guns blazing
Standish was already chomping at the bit
to do it and wouldn't you know all of
this had the effect of making all the
petty Sachems
much friendlier toward the English funny
how demonstrations of strength worked
this brings us to the first Thanksgiving
we wouldn't forget about Thanksgiving it
occurred around Michaelmas Michaelmas
which is in late September early October
contrary to popular revisionism it
actually did resemble not only our 20th
century ideas of Thanksgiving but even
the dinners that we have today it
actually was fairly similar there was a
lot of corn squash beans barley peas
they did eat turkey they a ducks and
geese they possibly also ate striped
bass and bluefish and Cod NASA so Ed and
his Indian pals showed up with around a
hundred people more than twice the
English population of the colony but he
knew his manners and he didn't show up
empty-handed he brought five freshly
killed deer the entire meal was cooked
by the for adult women who survived that
awful first winter half of whom laid the
genetic line all the way down to little
ole
this festival however was not religious
in the way that we would consider
Thanksgiving they didn't even call it
Thanksgiving the real Thanksgiving
didn't happen until two years later in
1623 when governor Bradford officially
declared a day of Thanksgiving this was
a civil affair recognized by the civil
authority and it didn't celebrate
English Indian cooperation as they may
have celebrated two years earlier rather
the pilgrims were thankful that year
that they ditched communism in favor of
private property which had in turn given
them abundance you see the pilgrims had
tried what they called the common course
not common core that's also bad but the
common course communal ownership of
property land and wealth turns out it
made everybody lazy dishonest and
thieving shocking I know
on the brink of starvation in 1623
Bradford instituted private property in
his words quote this had very good
success for it made all hands very
industrious so as much more corn was
planted than otherwise would have been
by any means the governor or any other
could use and saved him a great deal of
trouble and gave far better content the
women now willingly went into the field
and took their little ones with them to
set corn which before would allege
weakness and inability whom to have
compelled would have been thought great
tyranny and depression it's amazing when
you give people a stake in their own
abundance and their own work it turns
out they work more and by the way this
was not just a conclusion about a
particular experience Bradford
explicitly condemned communism in all
its forms and all its lies and all its
empty promises as absurd and contrary to
God's will he explained quote the
experience that was had in this common
course and condition tried sundry years
and that amongst godly and sober men may
well events the vanity of that conceit
of Plato's and other ancients applauded
by some of later times little did he
know of even later times that the taking
away of property and bringing in
community into a Commonwealth would make
them happy and flourishing as if they
were wiser than God within two years of
landfall these earliest Americans
already realize that communism is the
worst ante communism is as American as
apple pie and Thanksgiving while most
local Indian tribes played nine
the Narragansetts refused to abide the
Pokanoket english alliance and they
threatened war by sending arrowheads
wrapped in snakeskin to the Pilgrims and
Squanto they're not gonna take that
so the pilgrim sent bullets and
gunpowder wrapped in snakeskin right
back another reminder it is not a good
idea to mess with religious zealots who
travel around the world to live in
freezing desolate wilderness because God
is on their side do not mess with those
people ever now like any sane society to
protect against threats from without the
pilgrims built a big beautiful wall
around their settlement hundreds if not
thousands of trees were felled the
pilgrims lugged the massive timber by
hand and it stood more than half a mile
in length in over eight feet tall the
walls construction was met by shrieking
protests and stupid pink hats I'm just
kidding that wouldn't happen in America
for almost 400 more years Indian
relations continued relatively well very
often with the pilgrims playing
peacemakers and intervening on behalf of
their Indian friends with other tribes
when masses so it demanded squanto's
head after an attempted coup the
pilgrims begged for his life masses so
it agreed though likely he later
poisoned him anyway on his deathbed
Squanto asked Bradford to pray for him
that he might go to the Englishman's God
Bradford called Squanto quote a special
instrument sent of God for their good
beyond their expectation it's impossible
to argue with that he clearly was the
pilgrims at Bradford's command later
saved massa so its life by rushing to
his deathbed cleaning his sores cooking
him food administering what little
medicine they had doing anything they
could no matter how degrading no matter
how how ethereal for Massa suet to thank
them Massa so had told the english of
the massachusetts unprovoked plan to
attack the colony the massachusetts were
going to strike but this put bradford in
a difficult position the pilgrims didn't
want to attack the massachusetts without
provocation but if they waited for the
massachusetts to strike they were doomed
the massachusetts wanted to take care of
some englishman on their property and
they knew they'd have to hit plymouth -
so what happened bradford gave the order
Standish set the trap and the English
averted war by carrying the head of
sachem with to a Motte back to Plymouth
now it's funny to think of those
bush-era activists who squeaked about
how awful and
Siddhant pre-emptive war was for America
literally the first major military
assault waged by our country was
pre-emptive not only that it worked
war was averted and the Indians who
conspired against the pilgrims
apologized profusely
they made amends and masses so it
consolidated his power even further
creating thanks to the pilgrims for the
first time the Wampanoag nation peace
persisted for decades as the
Massachusetts Bay Colony and other
colonies were formed Harvard College was
founded Indians converted to
Christianity by the tribe full and as a
result Indians ranked among some of the
earliest alumni of Harvard I'm certain
they were far better educated than those
shrieking snowflakes today missionary
John Eliot translated the entire Bible
into a phonetic version of the
Massachusetts language since the
Massachusetts hadn't developed their own
written language both the old and the
new testament has happened sixteen
hundred years prior in Europe the advent
of Christianity threatened the political
power of Sachems because Christ's
conquest on of death on the cross
removed political leaders only claim to
Authority and this led to jealousy now
among other Indian tribes Peace and
Doorly unbroken for 55 years it only
broke when masses saw its own son Philip
wrongly blamed the English for the death
of his brother who more likely died of
appendicitis or some other natural
ailment Philip vowed revenge she began
selling off land to raise funds for war
and he thereby exacerbated the need for
war local Indians notably the Christian
and Harvard alum john SAS amman warned
plymouth of phillips plans for war many
local tribes rebuffed Philips
belligerence and sided with the English
Philip even made an alliance with the
French against the English an offense
unforgivable not only to you and me and
all right-thinking people but also to
the fierce and not infrequently
cannibalistic Mohawk tribe who promptly
sided with the English looking back it
seems miraculous that peace endured so
long until tragically the hot-headed
child of the pilgrims dear friend masses
so it acted on a bad hunch and destroyed
more than half a century of mutual
benefit and cooperation setting the
English permanently on their course to
possess the whole new world reflecting
the abject misery the pilgrims endured
at the Mayflower's landfill the miracle
of their survival and their great thanks
to God for protecting his people
William Bradford wrote quote what could
now sustain them but the Spirit of God
and His grace may not and ought not the
children of these fathers rightly say
our fathers were Englishmen which came
over this great ocean and were ready to
perish in this wilderness but they cried
unto the Lord and he heard their voice
and looked on their adversity the
quintessentially American poet Robert
Frost looked on the country's destiny
with an additional three centuries
perspective he wrote the land was ours
before we were the lands she was our
land more than a hundred years before we
were her people she was ours in
Massachusetts in Virginia but we were
England's still Colonials possessing
what we still were unpossessed by
possessed by what we now no more
possessed something we were withholding
made us weak until we found out that it
was ourselves we were withholding from
our land of living and forthwith found
salvation in surrender such as we were
we gave ourselves outright the deed of
gift was many deeds of war to the land
vaguely realizing westward but still on
storied artless unenhanced such as she
was such as she would become i'm michael
knowles this is the michael doll show
happy Thanksgiving
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Nolt show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017